somewhere in a corner of south wales is
a place that feels like it's from
another planet
this is the newport wafer fab where they
turn silicon into silicon chips and it's
pretty unique
these large circular wafers of pure
silicon are sliced into smaller chips
crucial in pretty much all electric
devices
and i've been in a few factories in my
life but now we're quite like this
we have to wear these clothes because it
is a clean room cleaner than an
operating theater all of the air is
circulated and recirculated through
these grilles here and look at those
orange lights over there that's to
protect these silicon wafers from harsh
lighting and it underlines just how
high-tech all the equipment has to be to
create these tiny silicon wafers that
play such a big role in our lives
and places like this don't come cheap it
will cost upwards of a billion pounds to
build this fabrication plant from
scratch and fill it with all these
machines this is where we print the
patterns on the wafers but the chips
they make here aren't the ones that do
the thinking in computers they do
something else less glamorous but no
less important they channel power the
chips we make
can go into automotive into cars as you
as you said and that can range anywhere
from from the
management systems the engine management
systems uh led lighting electric windows
so typically we might have around 250
exterior parts within any new car that
is built today really and possibly you
know made here in wales maintained in
wales
last year newport was taken over by
nextperia a netherlands-based company
with chinese owners
earlier this year the business secretary
said the deal would be reviewed for
national security reasons would it
facilitate the leakage of secrets or
intelligence to china but with the
government melting down the decision was
pushed back to september uncertainty or
changes in leadership they don't
facilitate a fast decision making so i
would welcome clarity on all fronts in
such a way that yeah that our employees
can
can move on and they can look forward to
more new colleagues
the investigation has basically put the
clock back a bit but questions are also
being asked about whether the takeover
will undermine the wider tech sector
spectrum moved rocklead photonics which
designed state-of-the-art sensors that
go into smart watches and health devices
was planning to make many of their chips
here but since next period took over
they'll be forced to shift all their
manufacturing offshore compound
semiconductor technology in the
healthcare industry can completely
revolutionize it
so we've got part of the chain we've
invested in and we've got the end of it
but the middle bit
what are we going to do we're going to
ship it off somewhere else
where you know we're going to lose
control of it um that we're not going to
get the full benefits and some
semiconductor veterans argue that
newport is and was an underappreciated
champion in its field it's got a lot of
advanced processing techniques in there
which many of their competitors can't do
nexperia couldn't do it so they went to
newport fab initially as a customer and
now they then acquired it so there's
special know-how there
that you know is is pretty unique to
that cluster in south wales absolutely
and that know-how
is likely to be transferred to next
periods factories in in china
this is no easy decision how to balance
these concerns and those of national
security against the fact that a plant
which having struggled for years has
fresh investment from its new owners
the final decision is due in early
september if politics doesn't intervene
again
ed conway sky news in newport